[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir cacher ce match de foot
que je ne saurais voir pour protester
contre la présence sur le terrain d'élus
du RN le parti Renaissance mais aussi
les insoumis et les socialistes ont
appelé au boycott du match de foot
caritatif qui a lieu ce soir à Paris
entre l'équipe de foot de l'assemblée et
une sélection d'anciens internationaux
tacler le RN plutôt que de lui passer la
balle au-delà de l'anecdote que signifie
ce geste politique et serait-il plus
grave de porter le même maillot que de
voter avec le RN dans l'hémicycle grand
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
sur ce plateau notre grand témoin ce
soir est historienne féministe
spécialiste de l'histoire des femmes et
du genre elle enseigne en France et aux
États-Unis et vient de diriger un livre
titanesque féminicide une histoire
mondiale mille pages conçue comme une
arme de combat contre les violences
faites aux femmes dans le monde
Christelle tarot et notre invité ce soir
enfin les partis pris de la franchi ce
soir Mohamed cifaoui nous parle de cette
note des services de l'étape photo
inoffensive islamiste sur le voile à
l'école Fanny guinochet pour l'économie
quand l'Allemagne
ose nous faire la leçon sur le nucléaire
et puis Isabelle Lasserre qui va revenir
sur le soulèvement des fans malgré la
répression il ne faiblit pas c'est parti
pour le menu vous savez tout on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs le foot oui mais pas
avec n'importe qui c'est une épidémie de
forfait qui touche l'équipe de foot de
l'Assemblée nationale ce soir ce qui n'a
pas empêché vous le voyez le match
d'avoir lieu le coup d'envoi a été donné
près de la Tour Eiffel à 18h30 tout à
l'heure on a pu admirer la belle
conduite de balle de carlolive qu'on
voit l'image pour la majorité julien
audoul lui n'est pas resté longtemps sur
le terrain puisqu'il s'est froissé le
tendon il se fait une grave blessure et
puis en face on a reconnu les stars le
voilà Matt Pokora le chanteur et un
ancien champion du monde 98 Christian
Karembeu qui lui est en bleu côté
Assemblée nationale c'est important le
foot les Français adorent ça au-delà de
l'anecdote ce boycott témoigne quand
même de quelque chose à l'Assemblée
peut-être une gêne une difficulté des
députés à se positionner par rapport au
leurs collègues du rassemblement
national bonsoir Jérôme Guedj bons et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes député socialiste de l'Essonne
votre groupe a appelé au boycott de ce
match bonsoir Christopher weisberg merci
d'être avec nous député Renaissance le
parti présidentiel des français établi
en Amérique du Nord vous aussi mal à
l'aise puisque votre patron Berger a
recommandé à ces troupes de ne pas jouer
ce soir bonsoir Laurent jacobelli
bonsoir et merci d'être là député
rassemblement national de Moselle à
belmestre journaliste politique au monde
qui connaît aussi bien le rassemblement
national que les insoumis et encore
mieux le football va nous rejoindre dans
un tout petit instant mais d'abord les
faits qui est sur le terrain ce soir
qu'il n'y ait pas et pourquoi si j'ai
bien compris c'est lundi blackovski pour
commencer
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
messieurs si j'ai bien compris ce soir
alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam il y a
deux problèmes avec l'équipe de foot de
l'asso la nationale le premier problème
c'est qu'elle est nue en attaque et le
deuxième problème c'est qu'elle est
catastrophique en défense alors moi je
suis chroniqueur LCP donc forcément je
suis à fond derrière mon équipe mais il
faut bien constater que les résultats
sont navrant je vous laisse regarder le
palmarès donc sur les trois derniers
matchs ils ont marqué 4 buts ils en ont
encaissé 32 donc il y a quand même
marqué Assemblée nationale sur le
maillot les gars il y a un moment il
faut s'entraîner il faut faire bon ils
sont pas joueurs professionnels leur
travail c'est d'être ici je dis pas mais
débute à chaque match mais je vois ce
que vous voulez dire je vois ce que vous
voulez dire c'est que jusqu'à présent ce
type de foot en fait c'est l'occasion
d'organiser un match chaque année dans
une un match de charité pour une
association et puis c'était le faire 130
sans trop se prendre au sérieux j'ai
retrouvé une image d'ailleurs de Guy
Roux qui est entraîné les une de ses
équipes à un moment et vous allez voir
que c'était plutôt bon enfant la manière
dont il expliquais la tactique
mais une entraîneur des parlementaires
Giroud c'est bien que l'équipe adverse
ne leur fera aucun cadeau alors il
choisit une formation assez spéciale on
va jouer avec 10 défenseurs et un goal
l'année dernière on a perdu 12 ans le
challenge donc le challenge commence à
11 et donc c'était une très bonne
tactique grâce à cette tactique de 10
défenseurs ils ont perdu que 600 allez
ce qui est leur meilleur résultat on va
se concentrer sur la politique
c'est du sérieux alors revenons aux
choses sérieuses vous savez par exemple
que l'autre joueur sur Public Sénat
manuel Bompard a déclaré que lui à titre
personnel il se verrait bien voter une
motion de censure même s'il était déposé
par le rassemblement national donc ça
veut dire jouer dans la même équipe que
le RN en fait pour renverser le
gouvernement donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très sérieux en
revanche quand il s'agit de jouer un
match de foot sous le même maillot des
députés du rassemblement national là ça
devient impossible on écoute les
positions de la gauche nous ne voulons
pas participer à finalement un objectif
de récupération politique par le
rassemblement national pour se banaliser
on considère que le sport c'est un outil
de tolérance c'est un outil qui véhicule
certaines valeurs et en l'occurrence
taper sur l'épaule de ceux qui ne
partagent pas nos valeurs ça nous paraît
pas opportun alors attention Myriam
attention tout le monde c'est là que ça
s'accélère parce que car le livre qui
était le député Renaissance qui
organisait le match il entend ça il
descend la salle des quatre colonnes il
cherche une caméra et il tombe sur celle
de LCP pour expliquer que franchement il
est pas d'accord avec la avec les filles
je trouve dommage cette espèce de
stérilisation cette espèce de fébrilité
ça en dit long malheureusement sur
l'état actuel des troubles de Monsieur
Mélenchon alors n'a pas le temps de
reprendre son souffle à peine a-t-il
critiqué Mélenchon que tenez-vous bien
de regarder Aurore berger qui est donc
la présidente ne comprenaissance donc
dans le même camp car le livre dit
exactement le contraire on ne doit pas
jouer sous le même maillot que le
rassemblant national on va finir par
demander son avis à Macron pour un
arbitrage sur cette question je peux
juste vous dire comme ça un indice il
est plutôt proche de carnoline Le Pen
dans tout ça ah bien Marine Le Pen
pourrait coûter tranquille je veux dire
89 députés à l'Assemblée 13 millions de
Français qui ont voté pour elle donc
elle attend 2027 peinard donc évidemment
ce matin on remarqué que la gauche la
désigner comme le Grand Satan et vous
imaginez bien qu'elle a eu beaucoup
d'embarras pour répondre parce que ça va
vraiment pas quoi dire
disons sur ces gens en réalité c'est la
haine tout le temps partout le combat
tout le temps partout donc en réalité il
vont à l'encontre d'une des grandes
valeurs du sport qui est bah que le
sport précisément c'est l'endroit où on
ne fait pas de politique puis alors on
était sur RTL elle en a profité pour
rappeler qu'en 2019 donc il y avait une
équipe il y a aussi une équipe de rugby
à l'Assemblée en 2019 Alexis Corbière on
le voit sur la photo était dans la même
équipe que Louis alios ou le même
maillot ça posait pas de problème il
faut dire qu'à l'époque elle est cyber
tenait un discours moins sectaire il
était content d'être dans cette équipe
et à travers ce 15 parlementaire c'est
l'occasion une fois de plus de
rencontrer d'autres députés de voir
autrement d'échanger avec eux de
s'apercevoir que malgré les désaccords
il y a des passions communes et cette
socialisation c'est ça qui fait le
charme de ce 15 parlementaires alors
comment expliquer ce revirement alors il
y a la tactique et il y a la stratégie
comme toujours donc d'un point de vue
tactique à court terme pourquoi pas
c'est pas bête c'est-à-dire que pour un
peu se défendre contre la polémique en
ce moment maintenance Bayou on profite
de l'arrivée de l'extrême droite en
Italie qui inquiète c'est vrai tout le
monde et puis on crée une polémique
autour de ce match de foot bon ça peut
marcher d'ailleurs ça marche on est en
train d'en parler maintenant d'un point
de vue stratégique si on parle à long
terme
moi ça me rappelle un peu la question
que pose depuis quelques temps François
Ruffin il l'a pose régulièrement il a
encore posé l'autre jour dans l'Obs on
se demandant est-ce que la gauche veut
abandonner les électeurs du RN donc
voilà la question que je pose c'est
est-ce que diaboliser le RN ce n'est pas
se couper de ces 13 millions d'électeurs
bon débat merci beaucoup merci pour ce
papier toujours aussi piquant Stéphane
Laurent jacobelli je vais commencer par
vous comment vous réagissez à ce boycott
je trouve ça excessivement ridicule et
on voit tous ces Tartuffe qui toute la
journée nous parle de tolérance de vivre
ensemble de compréhension qui lorsque
c'est leur tour d'en faire montre son
dans l'ostracisation de ceux qui ne
pensent pas comme eux sont dans une
forme de déni de démocratie
radicaux dans leur réaction je pense que
leurs actes viennent démentir leurs
paroles
il y a pas plu haineux il y a pas plus
et on le voit au quotidien on le voit
l'assemblée on le voit là sur un match
de foot le sport c'est formidable c'est
là où on a vu en pleine tension dans un
match de foot les États-Unis contre
l'Iran c'est là où on voit des nations
qui ne s'entendent plus depuis des
années où les Jeux Olympiques
concourir au même au même au même sport
et je pense que il bafoue les valeurs du
foot mais surtout ils essayent de se
refaire la pilule si je peux me
permettre la nuit pêche est en train de
traverser des zones de turbulences on
voit bien que le comportement dans le
cadre du foyer est souvent opposé aux
principes qui sont évoqués à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc ils ont besoin oublier
les affaires de violence conjugales ils
apparaissent pour ce qu'ils sont des
gens sectaires refermés sur eux-mêmes
coûter alors il y a beaucoup de mots
hein et fleuri clairement Tartuffe
sectarisme qu'est-ce que vous répondez
franchement sur le foot parce que on va
parler de ce que ça raconte
politiquement et de la manière dont la
gauche essaye de se positionner dans
cette nouvelle Assemblée sans majorité
relative notamment par rapport à son
adversaire on dit adversaire pas ennemi
le rassemblement national pour la nups
je veux juste être sûr sur les termes
adversaire en politique j'ai des
adversaires il y en a d'autres qui sont
un peu plus costaud que d'autres et
souvent le rassemblant national en tous
les cas moi dans mon identité politique
fait partie de ceux que je combat le
plus résolument et ils sont parfois des
ennemis notamment quand il menace un
certain nombre de fondamentaux et de
valeur de notre facteur républicain et
donc on peut avoir des désaccords vous
voyez
les valeurs qui ont été bafouées vous le
reconnaissez et international est-ce que
est-ce que c'est pas un peu hypocrite
cette posture franchement non il y a
rien d'hypocrites à être un peu un peu
cohérent moi j'ai aucun problème à
débattre avec le rassemblement national
la preuve je suis face à vous nous le
faisons dans l'hémicycle moi je suis
député comme vous
ça fait pas partie de notre contrat que
d'aller jouer dans une équipe de foot
une équipe de rugby c'est une sorte de
supplément d'âme qui peut être proposée
le rassemblement national est représenté
par 89 ou 90 ou 91 députés d'extrême
droite à l'Assemblée nationale et que
par conséquent on peut considérer que on
n'est pas dans notre rôle de participer
à une forme de
respectabilisation de notabilisation et
puis ce que vous parlez du sport c'est
un moment d'abord je suis pas d'accord
ni avec vous ni avec Marine Le Pen et
sous le couvert d'Abel Mestre le sport
et le foot en particulier c'est
éminemment politique c'est à dire que
c'est aussi vecteur d'un certain nombre
de messages on le voit dans la
préparation de la Coupe du Monde on le
voit sur une série de symboles encore il
y a quelques jours quand les joueurs
iraniens ont eu la belle audace de
masquer leur drapeau sous leur sous leur
soignée de députés RN on peut jouer
ensemble ça reste discret à 89 après ce
qui s'est passé en Italie
qui a un changement de nature
un changement de nature dans la manière
que nous devons avoir de nous opposer de
débattre de nous confronter et le sport
je le dis
vous voyez moi je joue au rugby j'ai
joué il y a 10 ans dans le 15
parlementaires c'est un moment en effet
de très grande convivialité c'est un
moment de solidarité de fraternité et je
vais vous le dire très sincèrement moi
je joue pas avec le rassemblement
national alors que je le combat par
ailleurs et je veux pas donner cette
impression de copiner avec le
rassemblement national et et c'est le
choix personnels
de cette respectabilisation et je
souhaite pas le faire et c'est en soi ce
n'est pas grave si vous vous sentez mal
pris du tout
il n'y a pas de gens respectueux et
démocrates il y a des gens qui sont
juste à votre choix c'est pas une
atteinte au respect ou à la démocratie
que de dire il y a des gens avec qui je
n'ai pas envie de jouer j'ai pas envie
d'aller boire de faire la troisième
mi-temps avec eux enfin votre colère et
votre méprise sera compris par nos
électeurs je ne vous inquiétez pas faire
tourner la page
j'essaye juste d'être cohérent parce que
sinon on va dire attendez on comprend
pas ces gens-là ils se battent
résolument dans l'hémicycle et puis
après il va y compris
la parole Christopher viceberg alors
vous aussi le parti présidentiel
Renaissance a décidé de pas mettre un
pied sur le terrain sauf que Carlo olive
qui fait partie de votre groupe a décidé
de ne pas obéir à aubergé mais
franchement c'est c'est pas un peu du
pain béni pour le pour le RN parce que
ce que vous êtes là quelle publicité
vous lui donnez moi j'ai suivi cette
polémique via avant qu'elle devienne
polémique il y a la boucle des députés
Renaissance et il y a 10 jours tout le
monde trouvait ça très sympathique tout
le monde voulait d'ailleurs participer
dans le dans le public
je vous explique un peu le comment le
contexte cette de cette food gate un peu
un peu surface et il y a deux jours la
nuit pêche qui a quand même décidé de
faire des polémiques et de faire feu de
tout bois a décidé d'en faire un objet
politique et là à ce moment là en effet
la question s'est posée dans le groupe
parce que les gens n'avaient tout
simplement au début pensé que c'était ça
et donc notre présidente a une position
d'ailleurs assez nuancée qui est
d'ailleurs une position que je trouve
très raisonnable et a dit d'un point de
vue personnel chacun fait ce qu'il veut
et je trouve que c'est tout à fait juste
parce que moi personnellement je suis
très mauvais au foot donc en général
quand on met dans l'équipe c'est pour
faire perdre l'adversaire mais en
général une photo d'équipe maillot
commun donc je peux comprendre que ça
devienne une polémique politique qui
encore une fois a été instrumentalisée
par la nupesse qui en a fait un objet
politique on pose une question politique
vous pouvez considérer que la réalité
jouer avec williamio et classement ça
posait pas mais vous avez répondu à la
question ce que je vais vous dire c'est
que c'est devenu une polémique moi je
pense que les gens qui jouent ont toutes
les raisons de jouer avec dans cette
équipe parce que ça fait partie je
dirais du cérémonial de ce de cet
événement et pour ma part je combattrai
toujours les idées du Front national
avec la même virulence sans
et donc je continuerai de me battre
contre leurs idées et je pense que tout
ça est une polémique qu'est-ce qu'elle
traduit cette polémique sur le plan
politique pour vous alors déjà qui a des
points communs nombreux entre le
football et entre le sport mais la
politique mais entre le football et la
politique et le premier c'est un peu la
langue de bois il est posture en fait et
dans cette séquence on voit que c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui parce que le
rassemblement national a beau jeu de
draper dans une sorte d'indignation et
mais bon c'est plutôt agréable pour eux
de se poser en victime d'une injustice
et de d'indée de démocratie Renaissance
idem avec ce qu'a dit Aurore berger de
se poser en voilà en conscience
anti-extrême droite alors que ils ont
passé beaucoup de temps à mettre un
trait d'égalité entre la gauche et le
rassemblement national pendant la
campagne législative qui revenait le
banaliser aussi donc c'était quelque
chose de qui est assez contradictoire et
puis je me souviens aussi de Gérald Dar
qui reprochait à Marine Le Pen qui était
trop molle vis-à-vis de l'islam donc
tout ça
participait de la même dynamique et puis
aussi la gauche qui a passé cinq ans
entre 2017 et 2022 à ignoré superbement
le rassemblement national et Marine Le
Pen à ne pas travailler dessus à ne pas
l'attaquer non plus donc et aujourd'hui
au profit de cette petite polémique
aussi pour ce voilà pour reprendre le
blason franchement
à mon avis personne n'est perdant parce
que la gauche
a mis le doigt sur sur ce problème et
moi je comprends que des gens qui qui
s'opposent et qui qui partagent très peu
de choses voire pas du tout de de points
communs en politique ne veuille pas être
coéquipiers je l'entends très bien après
c'est vrai que cette tradition aussi
donc c'est c'est pas non plus une
surprise c'est pas un coup de Trafalgar
voilà donc je pense que tout le monde
s'en tire plutôt bien c'est une sorte de
jeu de rôle en fait qui est assez
amusant à regarder de loin on va au-delà
de ce match de foot regardez aussi le
jeu de rôle dans l'hémicycle parce qu'il
n'est pas rare depuis cette nouvelle
législature que des voix de la nupesse
et du RN ce sont mêlés on va y venir
mais d'abord on va quand même prendre la
température de ce match de foot c'est
vous qui le suivez Clément pervaux vous
êtes donc sur le terrain est-ce que
est-ce que ce boycott est dans tous les
esprits ou alors on l'a déjà oublié
alors Myriam une quarantaine de députés
c'était préinscrits pour cette rencontre
finalement ils sont une vingtaine sur le
terrain il y a donc eu tout de même des
défections mais pas assez pour empêcher
la tenue de ce match 20 joueurs c'est
largement suffisant pour former une
équipe vous voyez la rencontre à lieu là
juste derrière moi en bleu il s'agit du
11 parlementaires en rouge une sélection
d'anciens joueurs et de personnalité
pour l'instant ce sont justement les
rouges les personnalités qui mènent cinq
business face aux députés l'ambiance est
plutôt tranquille plutôt détendu mais
c'est vrai que tout de même que certains
députés semblent passablement excédés
par cette polémique nous les avons
rencontrés avant cette rencontre je vous
propose de les écouter
en fait tout ce que tout ce qu'on
réussit nos collègues à ne pas
participer en boycotant ce match ils ont
simplement réussi
à faire la lumière à faire la promotion
de l'extrême droite ça vous agace oui ça
me saoule honnêtement ça me saoule ça me
saoule parce qu'on est pas là pour ça on
est là pour un moment un moment de
solidarité et c'est il y a ça qui le
compter oui oui moi j'ai hésité j'ai
hésité parce que parce qu'effectivement
ça me ça me réjouit pas complètement de
jouer avec des gens qui n'ont pas tout à
fait les mêmes valeurs que moi qui ont
même parfois des valeurs assez opposées
au miennes mais d'un autre côté les
députés qui sont là sont tous
légitimement élus par des électeurs dans
chacune des circonscriptions donc rien
que pour ça on peut pas faire la fine
bouche et on doit être là moi je dirais
qu'il y a eu des courageux
et puis d'autres un peu moins voilà tout
simplement il y en a qui ont compris ce
que c'était que le sport voilà c'est se
retrouver il y a un tas de Parlement à
travers le monde qui ont des équipes de
foot basket peu importe le sport
dominant dans le pays qui ont des
équipes mixes ou il y a des députés de
différentes
parties et là en France non on peut pas
voilà c'est
très intelligent comme des marchés vous
croyez que c'est ici qu'on va combattre
le Front national vous croyez que c'est
ici qu'on va combattre la France
insoumise certainement pas certainement
pas et il y a des endroits pour le faire
et moi j'en vois j'envoie un message
arrêtez cette politisation à deux balles
franchement
voilà et dans l'équipe des personnalités
qui affrontent ce soir les députés il y
a le chanteur Matt Pokora je lui ai
demandé ça sensibilité par rapport au
fait d'affronter des élus du
rassemblement national écouter sa
réponse et vous ça vous pose pas de
problème de jouer avec du rassemblement
national ça me pose pas preuve jouer au
foot tout simplement avec des gens qui
veulent jouer au foot pour la bonne
cause si on dit souvent toute l'année
que le sport ça rassemble pour
rassembler les gens donc si nous aussi
on se met à commencer à faire des
différences entre les gens avec qui on
joue au football ça risque d'être
compliqué
voilà et le chanteur Matt Pokora qui est
aussi bon footballeur puisqu'il a déjà
inscrit un triplet le score désormais et
de sibuzz à deux pour l'équipe des
personnalités les députés sont donc
malmenés ce soir merci beaucoup Clément
Perrot et n'hésitez pas à nous donner le
score final quand vous l'avez dans le
cours de cette émission si on prend un
peu de hauteur après ce match on se dit
au fond c'est plus grave de porter le
même maillot que de voter avec le RN
comme ça a été le cas sur le projet de
loi sur la crise sanitaire par exemple
alors je veux dire pour moi ce qui est
plus grave et le vrai les vraies
Tartuffe c'est
de voter pour le rassemblement national
voilà parce que on a déjà oublié cet
aspect au début de la mandature mais si
le rassemblement national aujourd'hui il
y a deux vices présidents de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est parce que des députés de
la République en marche en nombre on
fait le choix souverain rien de lui
parler des députés dans les postes clés
qui ont contribué à élire voilà et non
pas des électeur
à l'Assemblée nationale dans le combat
contre le rassemblement national enfin
moi je me rappelle que pendant
l'élection présidentielle Emmanuel
Macron en a appelé à tous les
républicains pour faire front face à
Marine Le Pen et quelques semaines après
les mêmes députés
ce sont retrouvés à prendre un bulletin
où il y avait le nom de députés durant
son national pour les élire comme
vicement de l'Assemblée nationale
quelques temps après alors que rien ne
lui est obligé moi les places
institutionnelles auxquelles a le droit
international je n'ai aucun problème
mais il y a des assemblées où il y a une
sorte de maintien d'un d'un front
républicain vous savez au Parlement
européen le Front national l'extrême
droite n'a pas vice-président au Bundes
allemand le Front national enfin pardon
l'AFD n'a pas n'a pas de n'a pas de
poste dans l'exécutif du du Bundestag
parce que les autres formations
politiques ont pris la décision de ne
pas porter leur suffrage et pour moi je
veux dire les postes clés mais vous me
répondez pas sur les votes les Français
ils regardent tout de même les réformes
qui passent et celles qui sont rejetées
je vous mets au défi de trouver un
amendement une proposition de loi du
rassemblement national que j'aurais voté
ensemble pour rejeter tel ou tel
amendement attendez si si enfin c'est
mon vote est souverain il y a pas
demandé impératif si je vote contre et
que Monsieur décide de voter compte
c'est son choix souverain et c'est mon
choix souverain moi ma ligne je vais
vous dire c'est je ne vote ni pour le
rassemblement national contrairement à
ce qu'on fait les députés renaissances
je ne soutient pas les propositions les
amendements les propositions de loi qui
sont proposées par le rassemblement
national et je trace ma route avec
l'ensemble des propositions voilà donc
c'est une confrontation démocratique
parfaitement parfaitement saine vient
nous expliquer ce soir qu'il y avait une
tolérance intolérante et qu'il y avait
une démocratie réservée à ses amis
politiques je crois que ça s'appelle le
débat la dispute de continuer je crois
que vous n'avez pas compris en fait
l'esprit démocratique c'est pas de
penser comme Guedj c'est bien penser
différemment c'est être facho c'est pas
ça la démocratie qui a parlé la
démocratie c'est autre chose
on se mouche hein
est-ce que vous acceptez qu'on puisse
vous répondre vous êtes décidément
un petit dictateur dans l'âme et dans
l'attitude
qui se moque de la charité
il y a un moment il y a un moment les
électeurs ont parlé ils vous ont choisi
il vous ont choisi chers collègues ils
m'ont choisi ils ont choisi 577 députés
comment allez-vous expliquer à ces
électeurs que la première force
d'opposition pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'Assemblée nationale
n'aurait pas de vice-présidente ce
serait une atteinte à l'esprit de notre
démocratie à l'esprit de nos
institutions quand je vois la gauche qui
refuse de voter un amendement sur les
surprofits alors que c'était dans son
programme électoral parce que c'est
amendement vient du rassemblement
national oui je vois une gauche sectaire
et je vois une gauche et je vois une
gauche qui ne comprend pas votre par
exemple
la proposition de loi référendaire sur
la taxation des super profits pas de
référendum depuis que je suis élu
côté des amendements des républicains
j'ai voté des amendements de tous les
partis de la nupesse j'ai voté des
amendements du MoDem et j'ai même voté
certains projets portés par le
gouvernement la seule question c'est
est-ce que c'est l'intérêt des Français
c'est pas est-ce que je vais pouvoir
après aller sur les plateaux de
télévision dire tout le mal que je pense
des parties qui ne sont pas mon parti
Facebook pas facile d'être un opposant
rassemblement national dans cette
nouvelle Assemblée vous vous considérez
89 députés il y a des règles il faut il
aurait fallu qu'il soit représenté au
prorata de leur poids politique ou pas
très clair j'ai toujours fait la
différence entre le rassemblement
national et la France insoumise et la
gauche et j'aurais toujours voté pour
aujourd'hui un réflexe de fonds
républicain pour un candidat gauche et
évidemment je ne voterai jamais pour le
RN donc la distinction de la
présidentielle elle est très claire je
tiens à préciser cela pendant
l'entre-deux-tours dans les
circonscriptions où il y avait des duels
LFI RN
n'a pas été clair du tout il y a pas eu
cette position
et donc pour une position de clarté
absolue surprise est aussi peut-être un
peu dangereux évidemment j'ai eu ce
débat à ce moment-là et j'étais très
claire sur le sujet pour moi il fallait
faire une une distinction absolue et
j'aurais toujours choisi un fond
républicain absolument les règles de
cette hémicycle évidemment nécessité que
un groupe qui représente pratiquement 90
députés est une représentation sinon on
nous on nous reprocherait de faire un
blocus et de faire un blocus
démocratique donc pour moi on peut faire
parfaitement la distinction encore une
fois sur les idées et dans le règlement
intérieur de cet assemblée qui existe
d'ailleurs depuis un certain temps faire
part à ce que les les présentations non
mais quand on dit la ligne de la ligne
de partage c'est autre chose vous avez
pris un bulletin vous avez voté pour eux
il a fallu voilà on s'envoie justement
qu'on regarde le sujet de Stéphanie
Despierre qui va vous montrer comment
vos 89 députés à l'Assemblée ce serve
aussi de cette enceinte de l'hémicycle
pour se normaliser voire
s'institutionnaliser on est très très
loin vous allez le voir en archives des
années 80 ou un certain Jean-Marie Le
Pen faisait son entrée avec une
trentaine de députés grâce à la
proportionnelle Stéphanie Despierres
en 1986 pour la première fois le Front
National et Jean-Marie Le Pen entra
l'Assemblée nationale et voilà ce que ça
donne Françoise de panafieux député RPR
et même violemment prise à partie
effectivement un député du Front
national a bousculé à Madame de panacieu
ce qui est tout à fait scandaleux
insulte grossière demande de suspension
de séance condamnation de l'absentéisme
parlementaire et surtout démarche
exceptionnelles deux députés du Front
national vont monter à la tribune
derrière le président de séance pour
surveiller le déroulement de la
procédure seul moi seul le président de
la parole s'il vous plaît puis les amis
de Monsieur Le Pen courent dans les
travées et vote à la place des députés
absents un vol de scrutin aujourd'hui 35
ans plus tard le contraste est
saisissant tiré à quatre épingles 89
députés du rassemblement national font
leur entrée à l'Assemblée la consigne a
été donnée par les chefs du groupe tenus
correct exigée la stratégie de la
cravate a remplacé celle du vous déclare
merci madame la Présidente sur le fond
sur le fond après des années à se
présenter en partie anti-système le
Rassemblement National veut démontrer sa
crédibilité vous l'avez compris nous ne
souhaitons pas être une opposition
d'obstruction mais de propositions
pas une opposition de principe et les
Troupes de Marine Le Pen ne veulent
surtout pas bousculer l'institution
à la base de l'article 64 alinéa 2 et
c'est un problème je crois qu'il faut
trancher dès le début de cette mandature
et il se battent pour obtenir un maximum
de postes au Palais Bourbon première
bataille les vices présidents grâce aux
voix macronistes le parti de Marine Le
Pen en obtient d'où monsieur Sébastien
Chenu et Madame Hélène Laporte ces deux
députés peuvent désormais présider des
séances dans l'hémicycle deuxième
bataille perdue celle-là la commission
des finances sa présidence revient
traditionnellement au premier groupe
d'opposition mais toute la gauche plus
nombreuse que l'extrême tout à fait
barrage ORL c'est
l'insoumiséricoquerelle qui est élu
désormais le rassemblement national se
prépare à ferrailler pour la présidence
des groupes d'amitié là encore la
bataille pour les places s'annonce
intense
alors où le Front national devenu
rassemblement national s'apprête à leur
affecter est-ce qu'on dit ce mot célébré
pour certains en grande pompe côté
Jean-Marie Le Pen plus discrètement côté
Marine Le Pen c'est 50 ans c'est le 5
octobre la semaine prochaine il a
beaucoup changé ce parti et est-ce qu'au
fond l'assemblée c'est pas au fond le le
principal levier pour 2027 pour Marine
Le Pen c'est un levier essentiel
évidemment puisque
on a l'impression que Marine Le Pen et
ses troupes sont dans une dialectique
qui est de pas être dans le système mais
dans les institutions en fait donc c'est
quelque chose d'un peu d'un peu plus
subtil que ce que faisait Jean-Marie Le
Pen qui lui était dans la protestation
ça Marine Le Pen en 2011 quand elle
accède à la tête du Front national
anti-système dans l'institution
elle se dit pas anti-système Marine Le
Pen elle se dit anti-système quand
on écoute bien ce qu'elle dit elle dit
pas je veux renverser le gouvernement
elle veut le remplacer c'est différent
c'est pas les mêmes c'est pas la même
approche de la conquête du pouvoir et
enfin en tout cas selon mon analyse mais
le
ce qu'on voit de cette institution la
différence de nature dans la dans le
dans l'exercice de de la de son mandat
entre Jean-Marie Le Pen et Marine Le Pen
après sur le fond des propositions il y
a eu des évolutions mais l'essentiel est
toujours là donc il y a toujours les
points fondamentaux notamment la
préférence nationale entre priorité
nationale dans le programme mais le
voilà le changement n'a pas été
entrepris comme on a pu le voir dans des
pays étrangers mais en tout cas sur le
style clairement sur la stratégie aussi
il y a quelque chose de différent
pour l'instant ce qu'on voit de vos 89
députés c'est une poignée seulement qui
s'exprime ils sont cinq ou si ça prend
de la parole le reste certes se tienne
correctement dans l'hémicycle mais ils
sont silencieux ils ont peur de quoi vos
députés je crois qu'ils ont peur de rien
je pense que vous comptes ne sont pas à
jour puisque vraiment on a regardé tous
les débats très très régulièrement c'est
les mêmes qui s'explique il y a les
réactions il y a les explications de
vote je crois que 25% au moins de nos
députés ont déjà pris la parole dans
l'hémicycle mais vous parliez de
normalisation vous savez moi j'ai le
sentiment d'être normal quand je les
vois le week-end quand je rentre en
circonscription j'ai l'impression que
mes électeurs sont normaux j'ai
l'impression que mes collègues sont
normaux j'ai l'impression que nous
jouons le jeu des institutions plus que
d'autres qui nous donnent des leçons
c'est à dire que nous ne faisons pas le
chahut en permanence on ne monte pas sur
les tables on n'insulte pas nos
collègues comme peuvent le faire les
gens de la nupaise dont on a
l'impression qu'ils veulent exister
avant de proposer
juste pour savoir une de vos collègues
nous a traité de fachos et de rats par
exemple je crois que ce sont des
insultes à nous bien sûr directement et
à tous les Français que nous
représentons nous sommes je crois dans
un moment où les Français sont inquiets
de leur avenir sur les retraites sur
l'assurance chômage sur le coût de
l'énergie sur l'identité et les valeurs
que portent la République française et
je crois que ce qu'il faut leur offrir
c'est une opposition intelligente qui va
dans le bon sens qui les protège
l'opposition de principe de l'agitation
des donneurs de leçons il y en a marre
il y en a marre de cette gauche qui
parle d'antiracisme à longueur de
journée et qui défilent avec les
antisémites il y en a marre de cette
gauche qui nous parle de féminisme de
toute la journée et dont on voit bien le
comportement il y en a marre de cette
gauche qui dit que vous évite j'essaye
de bien sûr de cette gauche qui nous
expliquent qu'il faut faire attention au
moindre gestes pour protéger la nature
c'est une question importante et qui
roule en 4x4 donc il y a un moment il
faut voir qui joue le jeu des
institutions qui fait des propositions
et qui est dans la posture Christopher
Weissberg la première ministre a eu
cette phrase et les mots sont forts ni
le rassemblement national
la France insoumise ne font partie de
l'arc républicain quand vous êtes à
l'Assemblée nationale près de son député
vous comprenez que ça puisse heurter
certains Français qui ne comprennent pas
ils le disent eux-mêmes nous sommes là
pour améliorer la vie des Français qui
nous ont élus nous sommes légitimes vous
assumez ces mots-là en dehors de l'arc
républicain pour moi il y avait une
gauche de gouvernement il y avait une
gauche pseudo révolutionnaire et les
choses étaient très tracées
entre les deux donc le monde a changé le
monde a changé par rapport à aux images
qu'on voyait de Jean-Marie Le Pen dans
l'hémicycle en 1986 et il y a une
radicalité qui s'est exprimée dans la
société qui aujourd'hui se retrouve à ma
droite et même en face de moi avec
encore une fois quelqu'un qui on a
partagé énormément d'idées mais qui
aujourd'hui a choisi comme famille
politique les gens qui sont extrêmement
radicaux qui sont anti-européens et qui
parfois ont un discours quasiment entier
pour vous dans la majorité
présidentielle le groupe dans le groupe
socialiste et quelqu'un qui est dans le
groupe de la France insoumise on est
peut-être dans une phase d'instabilité
parlementaire on ne sait pas ce qui
pourrait se passer dans les cinq ans
peut-être une dissolution jamais tant
que Emmanuel Macron est à l'Elysée il y
aura de ministre un soumis ou
rassemblement national dans un
gouvernement ça c'était pour moi encore
une fois
et d'ailleurs je crois que jamais ça a
été envisagé donc Jérôme il y a quelque
chose franchement de terrible au
parallèle qui a fait café Elisabeth
borne en mettant à belmetre le rappeler
un signe égal entre
l'extrême droite sa tradition et la
gauche dont le centre de gravité s'est
déplacé en effet vers un peu plus de
radicalité mais dont elle a parlé des
insoumis
mais dans son ensemble mais ce faisant
elle veut jeter le discrédit sur le fait
inédit qui a constitué le rassemblement
de la gauche et des écologistes autour
d'un programme dans lequel il faut me
dire lequel des
à la question républicaine sur lequel
sur laquelle des propositions vous
considérez qu'il y a une menace plus
intéressante encore en quoi dans
l'histoire de de la gauche il y a ça
rassemblement une toute petite question
pour se débat qui s'achève si d'aventure
le RN déposé une motion de censure vous
le socialiste vous la voteriez contre le
gouvernement ou jamais je ne voterai
jamais un texte un amendement une
proposition de loi une proposition de
résolution ou une émotion de censure
nous aurons le cas échéant
c'est un sujet qu'on a évoqué
en notre dans l'intergroupe pas plus
tard qu'hier et je pense que c'est une
erreur de considérer que on peut là pour
le coup soutenir une initiative du
rassemblement national ça participerait
d'une forme de confusion nous avons une
confrontation saine démocratique
républicaine à chaque fois que possible
mais on n'est pas obligé je le redis ni
de copiner ni de soutenir des
initiatives
journaliste pour l'analyse finale il est
il est étroit ce chemin de crête on le
voit bien à l'Assemblée il est étroit
d'autant plus que le rassemblement
national et si je me trompe c'est le
Joker me corrigera mais j'ai
l'impression eux voteront une motion de
censure
issue issue de la gauche donc marine le
penchée
symboliquement c'est c'est la motion de
censure qui est déposait par le
rassemblement national si elle est
adopté ce sera le rassemblement national
qui aura fait tomber le gouvernement
donc forcément il y a il faut pas
oublier que non seulement beaucoup de
d'élus voire presque tous les élus de
gauche ont commencé le militantisme
politique contre le rassemblement
national enfin c'est tellement Front
National et puis aussi c'était
l'argument que Monsieur giacobini disait
sur les électeurs les électeurs ne
comprendraient pas les électeurs de
gauche ne comprendraient pas un vote
d'une motion de censure du rassemblement
national je crois que les électeurs de
gauche ne comprendraient pas que
Monsieur Guedj finalement permette au
gouvernement de Monsieur Macron de
continuer et de ne pas arrêter la casse
sociale un moteur de recherche
on verra bien si j'ose dire merci on va
s'arrêter là merci à vous quatre d'être
venu sur le plateau LCP pour parler foot
et politique et bien plus encore on l'a
compris on va accueillir à présent notre
grand témoin les historienne féministes
spécialiste des femmes et du genre elles
ont saignant en France mais aussi aux
États-Unis elle vient de diriger un
ouvrage majeur extrêmement documenté
destiné à faire du bruit féminicide au
pluriel une histoire mondiale aux
éditions La Découverte qui nous
racontent comment on fabrique des
meurtriers de la préhistoire à nos jours
vous allez voir il y a des textes
inédits des alternances de voie qu'ils
viennent de l'université ou du monde de
l'art on accueille Christelle tarot
juste après l'invitation adressé ce soir
par Elsa mandinguevin
si on vous invite Christelle tarot c'est
parce que vous avez dirigé un ouvrage
pas comme les autres il vous a fallu pas
moins de 1000 pages pour retracer
l'histoire mondiale des féminicides
symbole d'un système de domination vieux
comme le monde aux quatre coins de la
planète vous brossez un panorama complet
des violences faites aux femmes
Christelle tarot vous êtes historienne
féministe membre du Centre d'Histoire du
19e siècle vous avez déjà signé un
ouvrage collectif sexe race et colonies
et aujourd'hui ce livre choc féminicide
la violence contre les femmes encore une
fois est ancrée est ancienne parce que
finalement elle est
s'il y a à l'histoire de notre espèce et
elle a été pendant si longtemps si
indiscuter que elle est totalement
incorporée et que la grande majorité de
sa violence c'est parce que même parfois
inconsciente non seulement chez les
hommes mais aussi chez les femmes
évidemment
féminicides un terme forgé au 20e siècle
pour une réalité pourtant millénaire que
vous faites remonter à l'âge de pierre
dans ce travail collectif on retrouve le
procès de Jeanne d'Arc accusé de
sortilèges les chasse aux sorcières du
moyen-âge où la tragédie des jeunes
femmes tuées par centaines à Suda droit
reste au Mexique toutes victimes de ce
système d'écrasement et de domination
des femmes par les hommes le patriarcat
du banal au brutal comme vous dites vous
dressez un continuum des violences des
injonctions à la féminité jusqu'au
meurtre dans ce livre que vous assumez
politique vous appelez à une révolution
alors Christelle tarot après des
millénaires de domination masculine
cette révolution
doit-elle se faire avec ou sans les
hommes et peut-elle se faire sans
violence
bonsoir Christelle tarot et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation va revenir dans le détail
c'est une somme sur l'histoire mondiale
des féminicides au pluriel c'est
passionnant et il y a énormément
énormément de d'articles avec des
approches très différentes des pays
aussi auscultés mais je voudrais quand
même que vous répondiez tout de suite
d'emblée à cette question qui vous est
adressée cette révolution vous utilisez
le terme et il est très fort que vous
appelez de vos vœux révolution sociétale
révolution des mœurs révolution des
mentalités des comportements est-ce
qu'elle peut se faire sans les hommes et
sans violence alors sans violence très
certainement puisque précisément la
violence c'est quand même au coeur de
l'idéologie patriarcale que je critique
très fortement dans ce livre et comme je
l'explique souvent la féminité les
femmes ont été construites socialement
je dis bien socialement et pas par
nature d'une certaine manière avec des
valeurs qui sont des valeurs
par exemple de non-violence de sororité
de bienveillance etc donc je crois que
non seulement c'est absolument
nécessaire de faire cette révolution
sans violence sans reproduire sans
reproduire des comportements qui sont en
même temps sont prédateurs agressifs des
comportements de harcèlement et avec les
hommes ou contre certainement pas contre
les hommes évidemment et là aussi je
crois que c'est très intéressant de
rappeler que par exemple le concept de
sororité qui est très très présent dans
le livre sororité renforcé notamment qui
est porté dans le livre par des très
grandes voix comme Aminata Traoré ou
Rita Laura Segato toutes ces femmes
rappellent que bien qu'elles appellent à
une politique des femmes de manière très
claire
cette politique des femmes et bien
évidemment elle peut pas se faire sans
l'autre moitié de l'humanité notons par
contre que pendant des millénaires les
hommes ont fait l'histoire la politique
la religion sans nous et que ça leur
aura pas Bosé beaucoup de problèmes et
que je m'étonne toujours que quand on
parle du droit des femmes à s'exprimer à
agir à penser on soit toujours d'une
certaine manière à nous demander si il
faut que les hommes y ait leur place je
réponds quand même très clairement oui
c'est évident que si on veut changer
notre société en l'occurrence française
mais même de manière plus générale la
société planétaire il faut que les deux
sexes travaillent ensemble les deux
parties les deux moitiés la domination
des hommes sur les femmes est très très
très ancienne c'est ce qu'on découvre en
ouvrant votre ouvrage qui remonte à la
préhistoire avec des travaux
d'archéologues dès le paléolithique les
inégalités hommes femmes sont là dès
l'origine de l'humanité c'est ce que
montre les recherches les plus
innovantes sur ces questions qui
Seigneur sont pas nouvelles puisqu'elles
ont commencé dans les années 70
précisément disons-le quand les
universités se sont ouvertes beaucoup
plus massivement qu'avant aux femmes
c'est d'ailleurs les femmes qui ont
porté cette relecture de l'histoire et
qui ont commencé à interroger y compris
les périodes les plus anciennes de
l'histoire de l'espèce humaine et donc
effectivement y compris chez les
chasseurs cueilleurs du Paléolithique on
note des sociétés qui sont peut-être
plus égalitaires que en suite au
Néolithique mais où on observe déjà
qu'il y a des rôles de genre qui se sont
installés et puis évidemment la grande
révolution en ce qui concerne les
discriminations faites aux femmes c'est
le néolithique la sédentarisation et là
effectivement on voit apparaître des
régimes de force qui sont très
structurés régimes de force qui sont
entre les mains des hommes qui
accaparent tous les pouvoirs
de manière générale donc ça va des plus
immédiats la guerre la chasse au plus
symbolique l'art la religion et en fait
cette première matrice de domination
elle s'étend elle se massifie et elle
traverse les continents et c'est pour ça
qu'en fait on a un maillage en fait qui
concerne l'ensemble de la planète et qui
se qui se construit c'est vraiment très
tôt l'ouvrage retrace l'antériorité et
l'universalité du patriarcat à travers
tous les mythes les mythes ordinaires de
toutes les cultures comme si le
patriarcat c'était une forme de choix
fait dès l'origine de l'humanité on a
jamais dans l'histoire connu un modèle
alternatif que la prépondérance
l'autorité du mal du père dans la
cellule familiale dans le groupe alors
dans les années 70 justement je vous en
parlais tout à l'heure beaucoup de
chercheuses ont investigué pour savoir
si par exemple il y avait eu des
sociétés matriarcales alors on a
finalement abandonné un peu cette idée
même si on sait qu'il y a eu des
sociétés matrilinéaires donc notamment
l'affiliation se passe par les femmes et
notamment par les maires
mais même dans le cas de société
matrilinéaire l'inégalité entre les
sexes n'étaient pas totalement absente
puisque il y a aucune société qui s'est
vraiment construite en dehors de la
stratification des sexes donc
il y a bien sûr quelques exemples
par exemple en Océanie en Papouasie
Nouvelle-Guinée en Chine de société où
les femmes ont beaucoup plus de pouvoir
et même même où elles sont très très
comment dirais-je très très
pas dominatrice ne disons pas ça mais où
elle est puissante et comme on dit
aujourd'hui
ce qu'on voit c'est c'est en fait des
systèmes de domination masculine qui
sont totalement généralisées sur
l'ensemble de la planète le patriarcat
engendre le féminicide c'est ce que vous
montrez à travers cette expression ce
concept d'un continuum
mais féminicidaire je vais y arriver
comme un fil rouge dans le livre la
dernière étape d'une d'une série d'actes
antifam du banal au brutal tout est lié
oui je crois que c'était très important
en fait de préciser ça alors continuum
féminicidaire c'est c'est une expression
un peu un peu entre guillemets barbare
c'est difficile de de la porter mais en
même temps c'était important de dire que
le féminicite bien sûr c'est pas
seulement un assassinat d'une femme
parce qu'elle est une femme par un
partenaire intime ça peut être aussi des
crimes de masse des crimes d'État au
Mexique d'air comme par exemple ce qui
s'est passé à Suda droit mais même par
exemple dans notre histoire européenne
je pense qu'il faudrait relire aussi la
question des grandes chasse aux
sorcières du 17e siècle avec un autre
regard d'ailleurs vous avez un chapitre
sur la chasse aux sorcières du Moyen-Âge
mais qui est encore aujourd'hui dans
certains continents comme en Afrique
comme en Asie d'actualité on accuse pour
chasse les femmes on les traitant de de
sorcières pouvoir de sorcellerie c'est
encore aujourd'hui le cas c'est une
drôle de discrimination de DD
légitimations des femmes et bien sûr que
il y a il y a un continuum en fait on
retrouve des des pro pour sorcellerie
dès l'antiquités et en fait ça court
jusqu'à aujourd'hui effectivement et on
en retrouve effectivement sur plusieurs
continents et même je dirais sur la
péninsule Arabie que on en retrouve bien
sûr en Asie en Afrique en Océanie donc
la sorcière qui n'existe pas la sorcière
c'est une construction fantasmagorique
qui vise à encore une fois
délégitimés en particulier le pouvoir
l'entraide les solidarités féminines
mais ça c'est une figure extrêmement
impactante pour évidemment quand on
parle de violence faite aux femmes pour
terminer vous vous arrêtez longuement
sur ce concept ce terme de féminicides
vous expliquer pourquoi en France il a
mis plus de temps que dans d'autres pays
à traverser notre langue c'est
passionnant dernière question le livre
s'ouvre sur des chiffres terribles qui
traduisent des pics de féminicides dans
le dans le monde une femme meurt sous
les coups vous dites d'un partenaire
intime toutes les 11 minutes ce les
chiffres des Nations Unies quelles sont
les pays les plus rétrogrades les plus
archaïques en la matière c'est une
question de d'échelle je dirais parce
que finalement les féminicides intimes
donc par partenaire intime sont
évidemment
plus important par exemple sur certains
continents des pays comme le Mexique
comme le Brésil comme comme l'Argentine
le Pérou tout ça sont très touchés
certains pays africains aussi mais même
en Europe les chiffres sont totalement
effrayants en fait on dit souvent qu'une
femme est tuée tous les trois jours par
un partenaire atti en France mais en
fait c'est plutôt tous les deux jours et
demi alors on dira que c'est c'est pas
grand chose mais si c'est grand chose
parce que ça fait beaucoup plus de morte
et c'est ça qui doit nous alerter c'est
à dire des sociétés comme les nôtres
comme d'autres sociétés qui finalement
tolèrent
l'assassinat de femmes parce qu'elles
sont des femmes et ça me fait penser à
ce que disait Virginie dépendent dans
son dernier livre elle disait si on
enlève le mot femme et qu'on remplace
par patron par exemple si tous les deux
jours et demi ou trois jours des
ouvriers ou des salariés mécontents tu
as un patron en France je pense que ça
ferait un petit peu de bruit un petit
peu plus de bruit
avoir plus de temps pour vous entendre
mais je voudrais que vous vous restiez
avec nous pour réagir à nos à nos
affranchir nos chroniqueurs féministes
d'une histoire mondial à la découverte
c'est absolument passionnant il y a
aussi des artistes qui montrent leurs
œuvres notamment en Inde c'est
absolument c'est d'une richesse
incroyable bravo pour ce travail que
vous avez que vous avez dirigé c'est
l'heure d'accueillir donc nos affranchis
pour leur partie prix ce soir Isabelle
Lasserre va revenir sur le soulèvement
des familles aliennes après la mort de
Macha Amini ce soulèvement qui ne
faiblit pas malgré la répression Mohamed
cifaoui va nous parler de cette note des
services de l'État qui pointe une
offensive islamiste sur le voile à
l'école et puis Fanny Guy ne pour
l'économie quand l'Allemagne ose nous
faire le son sur nucléaire nous
affranchis les voici bonsoir bonsoir à
vous trois Isabelle on va commencer avec
vous grand reporter au Figaro je ne le
rappelle pas on vous connaît vidage
familier de ces chroniques de fin
d'émission les femmes iraniennes déjà 13
jours de manifestations contre le port
obligatoire du voile c'est la fille d'un
ancien président qui a été arrêté oui
alors ça continue écrasé à Chemy une
militante des droits de des droits de
l'homme et droits des droits de la femme
aussi qui est aussi la fille de Raph
sangiani l'ancien président iranien qui
était au pouvoir entre 1989 et 1997 à
est accusé d'avoir incité la population
à manifester sur les réseaux sociaux
alors depuis la mort de Macha aminine je
ne sais de jeune femme de 22 ans qui a
été accusé par la police des morts
d'avoir mal porté son hijab et donc qui
est mort sous les coups la rébellion des
femmes est devenue complètement virale
dans tout le pays elle se rebelle contre
sur cette marque de d'assujettissement
patriarcal alors là on peut voir sur
cette vidéo par exemple où elle rend
hommage si la vidéo arrive si elle rend
hommage à l'une des victimes de la
répression en enlevant leur hijab et en
chantant mais ailleurs on peut les voir
couper leurs cheveux défier la police
debout sur des voitures la tête nue ou
encore brûler leur voile dans des feux
allumés comme ça en plein milieu de la
rue et la manifestation continue à
prendre de l'ampleur malgré la
répression des mots là et de la police
oui elle s'étendent non seulement dans
dans le pays où des manifestations
jamais très grandes mais mais très
régulières et elles ont été recensées
aujourd'hui dans à peu près 156 villes
mais elle s'étendent à une grande partie
de la société c'est-à-dire que on voit
beaucoup d'hommes et aussi une grande
partie de la jeunesse manifestée dans
les villes et soutenir le combat des
femmes alors là encore les hommes on va
les voir sur ces sur ces images encore
du foot iranienne ont décidé de porter
une veste noire pour cacher leur maillot
le logo de la nation pendant un match
contre le Sénégal en Autriche et tant
pis si ce geste peut en théorie les
privés de mondial alors la répression a
déjà fait 75 morts un chiffre
probablement sous-estimé plus de 700
personnes ont été arrêtées certaines
sources poussent même jusqu'à 12000
arrestations et pourtant la rébellion ne
se tarit pas alors pourquoi tourner la
censure du pouvoir qui a coupé Internet
les manifestants utilisent des réseaux
privés comme VPN et petit à petit jour
après jour la contestation élargie aussi
ses revendications il n'y a pas que le
voile mais les femmes certaines femmes
demandent la fin du régime islamiste
islamiste qui les oppriment depuis 1979
à la Révolution et certaines même aussi
l'instauration d'un régime laïque la
révolte est aussi sociale puisque l'Iran
traverse on le sait une grave crise
économique alors la grande question
c'est de savoir si la contestation peut
menacer le régime
si c'est une lubie d'imaginer quel
scénario c'est toute la question l'Iran
veut absolument à tout prix éviter un
scénario
identique à celui des printemps arabes
qui avaient secoué le Moyen-Orient en
2011 et en 2012 le régime iranien
jusque-là a réussi grâce à la répression
à résister à toutes les révoltes celle
de 2009 la révolte la révolution verte
qui avait contesté le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle à l'époque
mais aussi la révolte du pain les
émeutes en 2019 alors celle là c'est
insurrection et nouvelle car elle touche
vraiment au cœur de l'identité de la
République islamique qui a fait de
l'obligation de porter le le hijab c'est
principes fondamentaux alors pour
l'instant les mots là n'ont pas du tout
l'intention apparemment de donner du
lest ils sont viennent sans doute que
les concessions qui à l'époque avaient
été fait par le Shah d'Iran pendant la
révolution de 78 79 avait au contraire
encouragé les manifestants à aller à
continuer leur leur opposition dans la
rue elle avait accéléré au contraire le
régime la chute du régime impérial à
l'époque la police aujourd'hui a promis
d'utiliser toute sa force pour éteindre
l'incendie mais on ne peut pas
s'empêcher d'établir un parallèle avec
la Russie ou là aussi la révolte gronde
de plus en plus fort contre un autre
régime dictatorial alors on verra
Estelle tarot j'imagine que vous êtes
très sensible à ce qui se passe en Iran
comment sauvegarder ce soulèvement des
familles raidiennes qui vont jusqu'à
mourir pour pour leur liberté mais
malheureusement
oser c'est quelque chose de très banal
c'est à dire que quand les femmes
résistent en particulier quand elles
sont engagées dans dans un combat de ce
type il y a souvent des mortes mais ce
que je trouve très passionnant en fait
dans ce qui se passe c'est que ça craque
partout en fait quand on est un peu
attentif à ce qui se passe dans le monde
on observe que non seulement ça craque
bien sûr en Iran ça craque en
Afghanistan ça craque dans le dans le
Kurdistan iranien
irakien ça craque en Amérique latine les
femmes moyenne par exemple on fait des
manifestations monstres pour
demander des contacts en même temps
ailleurs parfois on l'a vu en Italie ça
se replie aux États-Unis
le paradoxe
et là où ça ça devrait être tenir que on
se trouve confronté par exemple avec
avec cette décision totalement
honteuse obscène la Cour suprême
américaine alors on va parler on va
passer si j'ose dire d'un voile en Iran
à un autre bonsoir Mohammed vous nous
parlez de ces notes confidentielles
révélées dans Le Parisien ce matin qui
s'arrête d'une véritable offensive
islamiste au sein de l'éducation
nationale qu'en est-il précisément alors
en préambule d'abord c'est vous
permettez je dirais la chose suivante
l'islamisme qui sévit qui tue des femmes
des hommes en Iran en Arabie Saoudite ou
ailleurs n'a rien de différent de
l'islamisme qui sévit en France et
important de le rappeler le voile est ce
qu'il symbolise en Iran Arabie Saoudite
au Qatar et ailleurs et en Afghanistan
n'ayant rien différent on voit est-ce
qu'il symbolise en France je le dis car
souvent il y a des confusions et il y a
des doubles sandales des féministes ou
néo féministes pardon qui condamne le
les agissements des Mollans en Iran sont
très indulgentes avec les islamistes
français fin de la parole
la note datée du 27 août évoque avec
précision une mobilisation en effet de
la mouvance islamiste sur les réseaux
sociaux et cette mobilisation vise
notamment la laïcité et introduit l'idée
de banaliser notamment le port du voile
à l'école à travers des artifices
c'est-à-dire de manière à détourner un
petit peu les les les lois alors ils
encouragent la quête notamment des
conflits entre personnels éducatifs et
les élèves et je dirais tout ce qui peut
avoir un accoutrement
identitaire et qui pourrait justement
symb réaliser cette islamisme sous
différentes sous ces différentes
codines de la loi de 2004 sur sur le
voile à l'école tout en affirmant une
identité vestimentaire
religieuse alors vous avez pu vous
constater vous-même cette offensive mais
elle est ancienne en vérité
l'utilisation d'Internet par les milieux
islamistes n'est pas chose nouvelle il y
a une trentaine d'années il faut le
rappeler les barbus comme on les appelle
toujours distribuer des tracts des
cassettes audio des VHS pour endoctriner
ensuite à partir des années 2000
Internet est devenu une sorte de bac à
sable pour les milieux extrêmes
extrémistes de façon générale et les
islamistes en particulier ils ont créé
notamment des forums de discussion où
ils incitaient les femmes les jeunes
filles notamment les plus jeunes à
porter le voile et parfois ils allaient
jusqu'à faire de l'apologie du
terrorisme avec l'avènement des des
réseaux sociaux cet outil extraordinaire
et la vitesse avec lesquelles laquelle
se véhicule et se propage les idées les
plus les plus dangereuses ils ont
investi justement cette cet outil en
ciblant comme je le disais surtout la
jeunesse alors pourquoi l'école est
particulièrement visée aujourd'hui
l'école en vérité a toujours représenté
un enjeu majeur pour les islamistes qui
savent miser sur le temps long on
l'oublie souvent dans les pays musulmans
par exemple ils ont endoctriné des
sociétés entières en investissant
l'école à l'école il faut le rappeler il
y a nos enfants à l'école il y a donc
cette pâte malléable qu'on peut
manipuler et qui est en plein formations
à l'école il y a donc notre futur le
futur de nos sociétés et c'est le ce
futur justement qui intéresse la
mouvance islamiste ils veulent le
compromettre et il faut qu'on en soit
conscient mais de plus au sein de
l'école de la République il y a trois
piliers majeurs me semble-t-il il y en a
d'autres mais trois piliers majeurs me
semble-t-il que l'islamiste veulent
fragiliser on est enseigne notamment la
liberté et qui dit liberté c'est
l'émancipation des êtres des personnes
des femmes des hommes en tout cas des
futurs citoyens il y a la question de
l'égalité notamment l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et il y a la
question de la laïcité pour finir il
agissent aussi en direction de l'école
parce qu'il se repose sur quelques
complicités il y a il faut le dire un
éducatif qu'il faut saluer encourager
protéger mais il faut reconnaître qu'il
existe au sein de l'éducation nationale
depuis quelques années une sorte de
complicité qui par conviction qui
parcinisme
des gens sont prêts à s'accommoder du
projet islamiste du moins de certains de
ces attributs soit parce qu'ils ont des
affinités soit parce que ils ont des
affinités avec cette mouvants soit parce
que ces milieux sont liés
idéologiquement comme c'est le cas d'une
partie de l'extrême gauche le parti pris
de Mohammed cifaoui ce soir Christelle
tarot on sait que cette question du
voile en France
divise les féministes entre les néo
féministes les féministes dites plus
classiques si on peut faire cette
distinction pour vous c'est un
asservissement de jeune femme le voile
ou pas oui un contestablement le voile
est un est un outillage patriarcal mais
plus généralement je pense que la
question religieuse doit être traitée
avec sérieux et pas spécifiquement à
l'islam parce que malheureusement il n'y
a pas que l'islam qui est touché même si
l'islam est souvent sur le devant de la
scène en ce moment dans les questions
sociétales qui interrogent nos sociétés
mais dans le livre on parle de toutes
les religions et moi ce qui me semble
très important c'est d'abord de remettre
en cause l'interprétation telle qu'elle
a été pensée dès l'origine parce que la
grande majorité des religions étaient
portées par des hommes et
l'interprétation de ces mêmes religions
aussi par des hommes et j'observe que
quand il y a des femmes qui
réinterprètent des choses sont un peu
différentes et je trouve qu'on devrait
plutôt entendre par exemple des femmes
comme Kahina balul qui est imam de
France et qui porte voilà une autre
vision de l'Islam au passage d'ailleurs
elle est dévoilée et elle s'en explique
souvent par ailleurs on sait que
le Coran n'impose absolument pas le
voile et donc ça pose la question encore
une fois de l'interprétation et du coup
je crois que on bénéficierait vraiment
beaucoup d'entendre pour toutes les
religions c'est valable pour l'Islam
comme pour d'autres Delphine nordviller
par exemple dit des choses formidables
merci beaucoup Christelle tarot je suis
désolé Fanny guinochet j'ai l'impression
que le temps qui nous a imparti est
terminé vous me le confirmez je suis
absolument confuse on va garder vous
voulez nous dire 5 secondes sur
l'essentiel de cette chronique on va
garder l'essentiel l'Allemagne et la
France c'est l'Allemagne qui quand même
justifie sa décision de laisser en
marche c'est centrales nucléaires deux
centrales nucléaires parce que du côté
des Français on assurerait pas sur
l'approvisionnement c'est un peu facile
de jeter l'eau propre sur sur la France
certes on a un parc nucléaire qui ne
fonctionne pas très bien mais surtout ce
qui se passe c'est que en fait
l'Allemagne rejette la faute sur notre
pays alors qu'on sait qu'ils ont eu des
difficultés à prendre un certain nombre
de choix notamment leur choix sur le
nucléaire n'a pas été n'a pas été simple
alors c'est vrai que EDF fonctionne pas
très bien on a 27 réacteurs sur les 56
qui fonctionnent pas mais c'était un peu
un coup de gueule vis-à-vis des
Allemands qui
osent nous faire la leçon et à un moment
où on va faire du nucléaire
c'est compliqué je propose de revenir
très vite et toutes mes excuses Fanny
sous ces municides au pluriel une
histoire mondiale à découvrir à la
découverte justement merci Christelle
tarot encore voilà pardon pour le temps
à demain restez avec nous c'est votre
soirée documentaire qui commence
maintenant
[Musique]